yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing hvc 1964 I just thought I have
an idea in the more oxy so we might get
this mouse on the ball but they keep
playing Knight c3 stuff against me so if
I just want to use this as an offbeat
ish of Beatrice wrong like once in a
while opening line I have to see when
you get something worked out against the
dragon line get played so often these
three is normal there would be wanna see
similar now b3 is what they do I might
also start with hook see one or
something
[Music]
let's see yeah what usually goes for e3
look everyone that's the idea that I was
talking about we should get put to e5 I
got their problems with this opening
line in blitz games i think i had one or
two games against a good opponent I
don't quite remember who it was but I
really got a struggled I really
struggled so we'll see what a VC 1964 is
going to do one black idea is to play
Bishop b5 Queen to e7 and potentially at
five it depends a bit on what white is
doing ok so here the Bishop b5 is kind
of kind of obvious and now one thing is
the I have queen age for sometimes
something that wide have to be on the
lookout form so he wants to play Bishop
g1 here really ok
I mean air for I can take on c3 and take
in forum for that looks dangerous really
really dangerous for what if i play at
five now what are you doing this let's
do it
yeah this is it can prove extremely
tricky this variation Wow a threatening
bishop h2 now for gage 5 and wow you
have time for stuff like that that's
it's amazing in the even look aged 5
like doing it on foot it's dangerous but
okay I can take age to what why why not
what is the trick that I'm missing take
the drug h5 and it takes on these six ah
that's the trick that I'm missing and
okay look age five just just like that
what is he doing then
and said Shh three Queens III is
stressful this one yeah i still have
special g3 here right
you
I th2 next move
something like that I look T for I will
take you 1 and cook h4 Bishop h4 is a
lookup really see no defense
why Rehan yeah i mean he's here now
basically the absolute optimum that is
possible there for black so yeah this is
some theoretical position and why do i
have to improve now kinking edge one
already gives gives white problems for
sure yeah after this engine is already
yeah wanted to play a for sacrifice upon
this is really not much wear that white
gets for the point it's also that when
the bishop 16 now is strong it's not
biting on that efore f3 chain and the
night only for is just a strong piece
reading 93 on top of it so there's an
immediate cream trade and it's never
enough compensation and here i think it
is this is probably already pretty bad
note that the move Queen to e1 is not
possible in our me winning this and Jeff
what what is he's supposed to play takes
rook takes losing you and to watch it
I'm attacking with everything in just
too much this will gauge five the
immediately captured doesn't work I
thought because of this but ok e5 still
wins here this is good enough if he goes
here I have queen d 3 or the engine
already statements made in five four for
something I didn't see that it is forced
necessarily yeah i saw the line that the
engine gives i mean this is a pretty
brutal line check check check check mate
neurol turn to flee check checkmate
there's pretty nice them you ply can get
very dangerous attack if white plays
from
yeah we have to say callously is why did
you ok guys thanks for watching